[Music]
you dare enter this house
putting out the pipe of debt it's gonna
be a good little session today
[__]
what's happening you bad [__]
uncle Joey deep deep deep in the jungles
in I ain't looking for higher wast I'm
looking for no [__] devil you know
I'm looking for the King of Swing
himself what's happening you bad
[__] it's the Lord's Day
washing your [__] scrubbing your feet
you ready to go it's gonna be a [__]
phenomenal week don't let nobody [__]
tell you're gonna get up every morning
the sun's out the birds are chirping
your [__] nut sacks filled with
[__] love juice everything is
beautiful you got to write your goals
but you know what they ain't gonna give
you the name running the [__] charity
out there you understand me you got to
get the sword you got to wipe it down
again I get ready to get down it's
[__] man you're still sitting there go
enjoy what I'm gonna do with my life
it's makeup sup this you could have done
a thousand patients if the lords they
[__] Uncle Joe is sitting here
I'm checking in with you making sure you
still black and beautiful I had a rough
week this week you know banging it out
the strike starts Monday so everybody I
get [__] done so I'll be around a little
more after Monday but the podcast is on
we got [__] Monday and 8:00 and
Wednesday and 8:00 and then [__]
Friday and Saturday
Mormons tell the [__] eight pieces of
[__] you got that you're putting them
on hold cause uncle Joey's coming to
town I'm coming up to morning land Salt
Lake City [__] wiseguys
I can't wait it's one of my favorite
runs the hotel it's close to a [__]
Olive Garden the busiest I love Garden
in the country I go in there and fart
and do whatever the [__] I want but
besides that it's great to see you guys
man let's kick back I got to clear
tremendous weeds today I got perennial G
but I got a [__] sativa I'm not your
[__] head off and this is called
power plant this is like [__]
sticking ten vibrators up gas or you
just rattle with that
standing beside that everything is comme
si comme shop it's been a great week and
it's gonna be a great week for you gotta
settle down you gotta write in your
notebook here I write your goals you
know let me know exactly what the [__]
you want you gotta get up every morning
and write on somebody's page have a
great day who loves you so the [__]
energy zips up after 30 days will be
reprogrammed you'll be a [__]
fighting machine you think I like saying
good morning with it beautiful day to be
alive no but you program the [__]
coconut to see things for what they are
beautiful [__] right or wrong
you'll need we you'll need nobody to
tell you that [__] I don't like nothing
else like smokin a nice ball on the
Lord's Day I'm thinking about gonna do
Jitsu but I want to give my me another
day to recoup I'll hit the bag I'll do
some situps I'll do some push-ups I'll
do the [__] steel bats but I'm gonna
get my me another [__] day you know
my Uncle Joe is getting old dog I'm 54
I've been jumping up and down member for
the first 20 years of my life before I
got fat was getting chased by [__]
burglary cop [__] like that but I found
oh nothing and I went back to the
[__] quest of getting in shape and
Here I am so now I'm getting a little
bit about try this in my knees but joy
what the [__] you're gonna tell me a
medical records are gonna smoke some
[__] refigure you're right I'm sorry
I'm you know the reef is putting my head
somewhere else oh yeah let's try this
[__] thing here I smoked a little bit
of it last night I was tip-top Magoo
listen if you came to Bakersfield this
week but you came to the house last
night I love you guys thank you very
much for love and support Bakersfield
this week was off the [__] chain let
me tell you something
you know man you go to these places and
ookami expect so much of your espresso
little [__] Bakersfield flipped me
the [__] out my people showed up with
movies people showed up with edibles
people showed up with reefer people
showed up with [__] in the the [__]
gray the sound but the Allman Brothers
ever did
peach whatever squeeze repeat whatever
the [__] lever is I can't think right
now I'm a little stone I love all this
type of [__] guys listen you guys think
I want to be on TV or jumping up and
down and listen to all the mutton I just
want to stand up commie I'm gonna do a
podcast I wanna do a little digital I
lose a little weight at all there's some
way [__] like I'm gonna keep it simple I
want to be a dad I don't want to none
you know why because I'm having such a
great time to understand them every time
I meet you guys every time you guys
listen to the podcast we connect on
Twitter or Facebook and then we made it
such a [__] great time it makes me
feel like I'm doing something my life
understand like I thought I'd be like
I'm gonna African building bridges and
help the [__] blind kids but you know
what this time once I meet you guys it
gives me the same feel like I'm doing
something I know I've got purpose so I
wanna thank you [__] for coming
for the show I'll see you savages and
[__] Salt Lake's to this week the
first time I went to saw like I didn't
know what to expect I tell us spent a
bunch of [__] you know people in
flannel shirts these [__] were
savages I wasn't I was completely wrong
but Joey what's with the [__] you
beaten I know I know
oh yeah oh yeah this is the [__] that
Klitschko smoked last night I think I
knocked up I didn't watch the fight but
it's everywhere
get him you don't need to why how many
fights you gotta [__] watch every
week we've seen you hating yourself in
the [__] head you gotta your [__]
concussion from watching Tommy goddamn
[__] fights anyway it's gonna be a
good day it's gonna be a good week
I said April is over [__] April Fool's
oh my god now that's it it's Mother's
Day in two weeks get your [__] together
get your flowers save your pennies you
put some little package together for
mine you know miles always defi a little
son put some ice on my knee I'm gonna do
a little writing and that's my [__]
world
I'll see you [__] come on night
eight o'clock be there or be square
two weeks I'm in [__] Milwaukee
Wisconsin on a Friday night the 12th man
I'm in Detroit Detroit sold out both
shuttles Milwaukee there's still a few
tickets left
you know I love you [__] I
can't wait to go to see my man bill
Rufus and see my man Matt holy and
[__] laying it down to people and
[__] this beautiful girlfriend you know
how we do it I'll see you tomorrow we'll
do another smokin on tomorrow we'll get
nice and high
[__] you know will philosophize on
how about the together about a [__]
week answer every week we get a little
bit like them to do whatever the [__]
they do this is how we do it every week
we move up a little bit better everybody
a little better what you do nobody sees
you coming you're the hand of Mona
Lisa's skirt plus you got a pinky in her
[__] everybody else is driving beam
is jumping up and down you're moving
like a thief and the night at the end
they're like that is better there's no
drama there's no nun by the time you get
there you look them straight in the guy
angle remember me [__] hey see you
guys tomorrow the church what's
happening now Monday Wednesday 8:00
o'clock at night I'll see you kind of
stuff it's a Friday and sadly Salt Lake
City wise guys I can't [__] wait have
a great day love you family I love you
mother [__] without you I have
nothing stay black